tankers of flame at sea
iranian commando storming a british
vessel
saudi arabia's oil production knocked
out by a mystery drone attack
this year has brought the gulf close to
open war
and this veteran saudi diplomat and
senior royal is warning the danger
is not receding we have seen no sign
from iran
that they are pulling back on their
very negative and provocative
military posture
not just toward saudi arabia but towards
the rest of the countries in the area
how concerned does that make you very
concerned nobody
wants war that's for sure because
nobody will be a winner in a military
conflict
the destruction will be universal prince
turki al-faisal speaks from decades of
experience
former ambassador in both the uk and u.s
his comments underlined the tensions
plaguing the gulf
to the south saudi arabia governed by
young crown prince mohammed bin salman
whose judgment remains in question
in the wake of the war in yemen and
murder of journalist jamal khashoggi
to the north shia power iran feeling the
strain of u.s sanctions
and under increasing pressure internally
[Applause]
the country has seen some of its worst
unrest in recent months
government buildings torched security
forces openly confronted
analysts say that may make the regime
there increasingly desperate
there is a chance that the iranian
regime might lash out
not only because it wants a distraction
but because it actually thinks
that these protests which i believe are
genuine popular protests and grievances
against the regime
are being sponsored from the outside
complicating matters under donald trump
the u.s has sided openly with the saudis
giving up the attempt to even hand it
diplomacy
if the tensions of 2019 erupt again next
year
there may be little to hold back either
side from sliding into open conflict
dominic waghorn sky news